Proteste in Deutschland ich hoffe Zeit
nicht dass er seinen Protest Winter
geben wird ich wäre aber auch nicht
überrascht wenn die Proteste im Winter
zunehmen wichtig ist dass man nicht nur
die Oberfläche des Geschehens ansieht
sondern begreift wie sich das nun seit
etlichen Jahren aufschichtet denken wir
zurück an die Unzufriedenheit oder
besser gesagt an die Sorgen vieler
Deutschen ob der deutschen Rolle in der
Euro Rettungspolitik Übernahme von
Bürgschaften Garantien für dieses und
jenes nach der
[Applaus]
eurozonenpolitik kommt dann die große
Migrationspolitik wir schaffen das und
es ist unmöglich eine Obergrenze von
etwa 200.000 Leuten pro Jahr die wir
aufnehmen einzuführen der Staat ist
allmählich hilflos in Bezug auf diesen
Bürgerprotest die alten Rezepte
funktionieren nicht mehr das merken die
Bürger wiederum und so sind wir in einer
aufschaukelnden Spirale und wir alle
warten darauf dass man Weg finden diese
Spirale ändern zu durch